in almost 15 years since we first saw
them mafia game break out onto the PC is
all pi played it on the city of lost
heaven and Matthew 2 was kind of a good
game was okay wasn't for wasn't too
fantastic yeah but fans were very happy
to see the Mafia 3 has been announced to
Peter Brown although some of those fans
took a little bit of exception to the I
guess the the focus the character
perhaps and the time in the setting
first of all Peter Matthew 3 you saw
some of it what did you think of what
you saw uh I mean there are two sides to
Mafia 3 that are worth talking about
right I mean there is the gameplay
aspect where you know it is a game
that's very much got the whole you know
a lot of shooting a lot of driving you
know kind of does a lot of the same
stuff that GTA does and something that
mafia has done in the past but the
series is taking a very interesting term
in turn in terms of the the setting and
the themes so it's said in 1960s or 1968
I believe and in New Orleans which is a
very iconic city for many reasons but I
think what most people are interested in
for I mean I'd like to think for better
but also unfortunately for worse is the
race of the main character you play
Lincoln clay who is a you grew up an
orphan and he's sort of spent his whole
life searching for a family right you
know he joined the church joined gangs
ultimately ended up in the army going to
the Vietnam War and now he's on the
streets of New Orleans trying to find
life in the the Mafia scene which is all
really interesting but you know he is
also a black man and at that period in
North America especially in the south
racism you know segregation where were
big deals and and they were they
presented a whole lot of difficulties
for a man like Lincoln clay and so this
subject matter is unusual for a video
game and based on the short amount of
you know footage that I saw the game
yeah I I don't know if mafia 3 is gonna
do this subject matter justice but it
could I mean we have to wait and see it
seems like the sort of era and the sort
of story that you would really need to
dive into headfirst to do it justice
yeah what about it what you've seen so
far sort of let you think that perhaps
they're there they're using a more
window dressing or than really it being
like the focus will what's giving you
that impression right now it's a scary
prospect for any developer you've gotta
say as well dude it's difficult for me
to even talk about it yeah yeah you know
like I I certainly don't represent
anyone except people like myself we have
my own perspective and that is not who
the main character is but you know to me
I can't say that I think it's just
window dressing right you know I don't
know that but the issues of race come up
at many points during the demo that I
saw which you know included you know
racial slurs being you know thrown at
Lincoln at other characters and it was
done in such a way where the people
doing it were pretty nonchalant about it
which I can only imagine was what it was
like back then it doesn't I don't think
that they're using that just to sort of
raise alarms and and stir up controversy
I think there's a really interesting
discussion to have here and you know
it's for a video game to be something
that is one a medium for storytelling
but also a medium for you know if we
said in case of Mafia like action and
gameplay and stuff like that it's that's
where I see perhaps the biggest
opportunity for this to fall apart you
know frankly I the gameplay to me
compared to the story set and the
setting is I almost don't care like yeah
I think there's a really interesting
story to be told here for sure like
African Americans have been not very
represented in video games history right
and I remember probably growing up for
me in Ireland that maybe that the first
one I really recognized what CJ in San
Andreas and then you've got a situation
in which your african-american character
is one that's involved in criminal
activities in gang culture in a
fictional version of California why not
and we've seen it in Assassin's Creed
we've seen I'm more african-american
over the course of the past couple years
you've just seen greater diversity we've
seen a lean towards great anniversary in
videogames in relation to gender and
race as well and I want to talk to you
about one aspect of us which is that
kind of I kind of hate talking about it
because we're basically like recognizing
what should perhaps be ignored but like
one of the things I noticed on the video
we put up a game
calm and on your story as well as this
sort of this like vitriol that is
backlash to it being used almost as if
the idea of having an african-american
by its definition as a main character
was some sort of plea to appeal to like
the left audience or it's some sort of
like a bending of the knee to some sort
of liberal and ideas what do you think
about that it does it's a more to do
with sort of most Caucasians that we we
immediately jump to that that like you
can't tell a story about the Mafia
because it's about the Italian mob with
a black person it's I mean I don't think
it's one thing hmm
from my perspective I think it's
partially fear on behalf of the audience
because they might not want to be
confronted with these issues I saw
several people saying great another game
where I'm gonna be told that I'm a
racist right yeah yeah and and that's
not why this is important it's not to
tell white people that they shouldn't be
proud of who they are or whatever but
what this is is an opportunity for a a
group of society that is very much
important as any other group to have a
chance to have their story told and
examined and you know what their
perspective understood so to see people
sort of backlash at this I think yes
comes from a place of fear and you know
it's it's also immaturity people are
failing their argument and you know
these are mafia games like why should it
have why isn't it why isn't an Italian
per unit protagonist why isn't Joe Pesci
every right video games protagonist
right it's look I think there's there's
no place for for hate in any part of
society it just doesn't do anyone any
good and if you don't identify with the
character then that's maybe not a game
that you need to concern yourself with
yeah but there are plenty of people who
are interested in seeing these different
stories be told and participating in
these discussions so I implore people to
just have an open mind and really just
think about what opportunities this game
presents that other games just fail to
mm-hmm I guess last question about this
do you think were we do you think we
will start to see I guess where we tend
to see a lot of the time now is is that
there is more diversity in
games not just in the main protagonist
but in terms of the stories were seeing
in terms of the different experiences
we're seeing and you know everyone's
gone to the rapture came out this week I
remember when gone home came out a
couple years ago the amount of vitriol
that was getting poured at that game at
the time saying this isn't a game we're
seeing a bit of that with the latest
game but it's not to the same level so
do you think that we are slowly but
surely creeping towards a medium in
which these types of things can be
talked about and these types of games
can be announced and it's celebrated and
less so than that we're seeing less of
this sort of weird you know overly
sensitive backlash to it do you think
we're getting there or does it feel like
it's the same as it was five ten years
ago I think we're in the midst of the
struggle that will turn the tide I don't
think we've gotten to the point where
we're gonna be able to tell these
stories without there being some sort of
controversy behind the announcement
people will continue to be upset about
it until it becomes something that isn't
an exception to the rule but it's part
of the general you know flow of the
industry and yeah we're probably going
to see some people you know try to make
games because they want more diversity
and that's fine like that's a worthy
cause and I think to shy away from
something like that is I don't see the
value in shying away from trying to
welcome more people into gaming so you
know I don't think I don't think it's
ever going to be fair representation for
all groups in society at any point I
think you know the majority will still
unfortunately the yeah yeah the majority
that want to just play like a white male
you know will continue to get what they
want but you know I really hope games
like mafia can come out and handle these
discussions properly and show people
that these are things worth having and
worth discussing but I don't think we're
at that point yet where a game like this
can come out and not be judged by the
color of the main characters skin that
that is obviously still an issue and who
knows what it's going to take so much of
a Stein for games an exciting time as
well clearly we're seeing some some
games coming out there and pushing at
the boat and it it's not not a dime sign
too soon as well
Peter Brown thank you so much come on